Швидкість люблю! Дуже люблю! Воно класно:
вітер в обличчя, шум дороги, шум мотоцикла…
Він гурчить своєю мотоциклетною мовою...
Натиснути на газ та позмагатися з вітром, хто швидший.
Це те, що 22-річна байкерша Вікторія Осипчук любить найбільше.
Свій мотоцикл ніжно називає "Джмелик"
і каже, що може розігнатися на ньому до 140 кілометрів на годину.
Може, але ніколи цього не робила…
Вікторія - волонтер-рятувальник громадської організації "Мотохелп".
Вже 12 років, як активісти руху виїздять на місця дорожньо-транспортних пригод,
щоб рятувати життя постраждалим.
Свій перший виїзд добре пам’ятає.
Тоді хлопчину під машиною протягнуло енну кількість метрів, і я приїхала на виклик.
Ми поїхали одразу в лікарню.
Я стажер, який вперше наживо бачить ДТП, це було важко.
А потім ми поїхали ще на одну ДТП, де фура знесла мотоцикл,
і, чесно кажучи, в той момент я задумалася, чи готова я взагалі до таких випробувань…
Нині Вікторія не лише виїздить на виклики. Вона - одна з шести операторів організації.
Це означає, що дівчина має бути на зв'язку 24 години на добу.
Інформацію про ДТП отримує з телеграм-каналу Motohelp Chat, до якого може долучитися кожен.
Вона першою реагує на виклики, спілкується з потерпілим чи свідком аварії,
розшукує родичів, ухвалює рішення: їхати волонтеру на місце ДТП чи ні.
На все це має лічені хвилини.
Напевно, найважче в цій історії операторства - це
телефонувати родичам,
коли їх знайшли, і сказати, що чоловік, син, брат, донька потрапили в ДТП,
і він в лікарні, і потрібно, щоб ви приїхали,… сльози.
Оце..
Нещодавно MotoHelp підписали договір про співпрацю
з "Центром екстреної медичної допомоги та медичних катастроф Києва".
Тож, тепер байкери виходитимуть на виклики разом з медбригадами.
Коли в місті затори, дістатися до місця ДТП на байках можна в рази швидше.
Ці секунди й рятують життя…
Як це працює, на власні очі переконалася DW.
У свій післяробочий час на зміну вийшли байкери Дмитро і Артем.
Ми встигли лише представитися, як одразу повідомлення від Вікторії:
на проспекті Перемоги збили пішохода. Рятувальники виїжджають негайно.
У даному випадку до нас надійшов виклик, що був збитий пішохід.
Ми приїхали на місце, але "швидка" приїхала раніше. Зараз ми повертаємося на станцію та далі чергуємо.
Утім, до станції волонтери не доїхали: наступне повідомлення - ДТП біля метро "Печерськ".
Їхати доводиться через все місто.
В умовах карантину дороги порожні, тож, "швидка" вже на місці.
Тут автівка збила мотоцикліста, що розвозив їжу.
Байкер Артем розповідає: окрім домедичної допомоги учасники ДТП потребують також правової підтримки таконсультації.
Адже після аварії перебувають в стані шоку, забувають елементарні правила.
У цьому випадку ми зберемо інформацію промісце ДТП,
дані людей, які потрапили в ДТП,
постраждалому надамо звіт з описом механізму ДТП.
Це йому може допомогти в суді.
Групу мотоциклістів-ентузіастів, які перетворилися на справжніх рятівників на двоколісних,
об’єднав 12 років тому байкер Дмитро Буренін.
Його надихнув досвід США, європейських країн та Ізраїлю.
Там такий волонтерський рух існує вже багато років.
Ідея була. Було просто цікаво, як допомогти людині.
Я проїжджав повз ДТП,  зупинився.. Думаю, треба ж допомогти, там мотоцикліст був,
а що робити, я не знаю. І воно ось так одне за одним зачепилося.
Почалось інформування, почала команда зростати, ми почали прописувати протоколи.
Для України це й досі революційна ініціатива:
медики не завжди з розумінням ставляться до такої допомоги.
На підстанції не дуже сподобалась реакція.
Деякі дивився на кшталт, навіщо вам це треба, а деякі: о, круто, ну, давайте спробуємо.
Я бачу, що поки що реакція бригад ЕМД позитивна, і сподіваємось, що так і надалі буде.
"Мотохелпери" також займаються екстреною доставкою компонентів крові.
У центрах крові кажуть, що нині така допомога як ніколи необхідна.
Адже в умовах карантину і надзвичайного стану запаси крові в лікарнях зменшилися.
А отже, слід готуватися до випадків, коли кров від донора до пацієнта
потрібно буде доставляти терміново.
Мені подобається.
Напевно, це маленьке щастя - розуміти, що ти можеш допомогти людям,
що ти можеш бути їм корисним, що можеш врятувати людину
і надати підтримку, яка їй потрібна зараз. Це класно!
За минулий рік байкери понад шістсот разів виїжджали на місце ДТП.
А щоб доставити кров для пацієнтів - подолали три тисячі кілометрів.
Як і кожен волонтер-рятувальник, Вікторія хотіла б,
аби кількість ДТП на українських дорогах зменшувалася.
А мотор на її жовто-чорному "Джмелику" заводити доводилося лише для безтурботних поїздок.